while we all know hollywood like every
other business was affected by the
pandemic what we didn't see coming was
the deluge of bad movies that would be
released afterwards from disappointing
blockbusters to pandemic pictures that
should have never seen the light of day
these are the worst movies of 2021
a decade after his film another earth
became the talk of sundance writer
director mike cahill added another
reality bending sci-fi romance to his
resume released in february 2021
amazon's bliss stars owen wilson as a
man who suffers a breakdown when his
marriage and job implode in quick
succession craig then gets sucked into a
world of powerful hallucinogens after
falling in with a homeless woman named
isabel played by salma hayek she almost
convinces him that the place they're
escaping to a place where she's a genius
scientist running a simulation and the
world's problems have largely been
solved is the one true reality those
with the required patience will
eventually discover that greg has
actually become a homeless addict or so
it seems bliss was made available to
stream at a time when audiences
desperately needed an escape from
reality but the film only succeeds in
dumbfounding viewers
come on baby we have to exit this stupid
simulation
indiewire wrote in its review even the
worst simulation would have more clarity
than this cahill's biggest error is
spending way too much time explaining
the mechanics of his universe though
exposition overload is far from the only
issue here the truth is co-stars owen
wilson and salma hayek lack the
on-screen spark that bliss sorely needs
neither seems totally committed and it
becomes increasingly harder to root for
them when the only thing that appears
genuine is wilson's look of bewilderment
a handful of movies have been created
and set within the pandemic but for
every host a zoom set thrill ride
there's a total disaster like lockdown
part highscaper part romantic drama the
film follows linda and paxton played by
anne hathaway and chuatel egyuphore they
are a struggling couple whose planned
separation has to be put on hold due to
coven 19 lockdown restrictions in london
holed up together they decide to plan an
audacious jewelry heist that will make
the millionaires using paxton's delivery
driver job and linda's access to the
harrods vaults then they'll steal a
diamond worth over 4 million dollars
give half the proceeds to the national
health service and go their separate
ways of course things don't pan out that
way the heist just brings them closer
together writer stephen knight and
director doug lyman imply that paxton
and linda are going to use the rest of
lockdown to fall in love all over again
both leads put in an admirable effort
but locked down is too concerned with
winks and nods to lockdown life often
ignoring the whole heist plot for long
stretches of time the times shared their
opinion saying the entire film in short
is an abominable mistake sadly we agree
the second doug lyman movie released in
as many months during the early part of
2021 the long-awaited adaptation chaos
walking was another bust for the
talented director the property was
lauded as the next twilight by reuters
when it revealed that lionsgate had
acquired the movie rights way back in
2011. lyman boarded the project in 2016
and by the end of the year both daisy
ridley and tom holland had signed on to
star filming went ahead but early
reactions to the movie were so bad with
execs at lionsgate reportedly calling it
unreleasable after seeing the first cut
that major reshoots were ordered
unfortunately daisy ridley and tom
holland were too busy becoming huge
names via the star wars and marvel
movies the brief obsession with
dystopian young adult films had long
since passed by the time chaos walking
made it to the big screen in march 2021
however even if this intended franchise
starter had been released alongside the
likes of the hunger games and the maze
runner it would have struggled nobody
really expected chaos walking to be a
game changer after it spent so long in
development hell but it still managed to
disappoint
on paper breaking news in yuba county
was a sure fire hit however this dark
comedy about a suburban housewife who
strings the news media along with a lie
about her cheating husband missed its
mark by a considerable distance with
oscar winner allison janney leading the
line and a great supporting cast
director tate taylor had a chance to do
something special with the film but
sadly breaking news in yuba county comes
off as a derivative version of the films
it aspires to rubbed shoulders with
unfavorable comparisons to coen brothers
classic fargo were popular among the
critics unlike the film itself which was
panned hard when it was released
digitally and in theaters in february
2021 besides wasting a talented cast the
biggest sin of breaking news in yuba
county is overindulging in gratuitous
violence
it's not nice to point guns at people
the hollywood reporter shared the bursts
of brutality explicit and suggested land
somewhere on a spectrum between
tarantino and looney tunes and not in a
good way meanwhile in a no-holds-barred
review the new york times questioned how
a filmmaker like taylor came to direct
this quote a moral repellent bag of sick
writer amanda idoko of the goldbergs
clearly had something to say about
tabloid culture but her message gets
bungled badly
a sci-fi misfire that lives up to its
name cosmic sin stars a lethargic bruce
willis as a disgraced general who comes
out of retirement to fight a hostile
extraterrestrial race the action takes
place in a far-off future where
humankind has long since colonized
planets outside our solar system war
seems inevitable when one such planet is
attacked by hitherto undiscovered
civilization and the odds are of course
stacked against humanity knowing it's
their only shot willis and frank grillo
of captain america the winter soldier
lead a preemptive strike on the alien
army's home planet the film continued a
dreadful run of form for willis who came
under heavy fire in the reviews christy
lemire of rogerdeeper.com wrote of the
film to suggest that bruce willis is
phoning in his performance in cosmic sin
would be an insult to telephone
communication which can be an effective
means of conveying important information
and genuine emotion
it's given me a lot to think about
the los angeles times also noted that
the fated action star was somehow more
lackluster than usual could a different
more interesting lead have saved this
film in short
no the criticism leveled at willis was
indeed valid but co-writers edward drake
who also directed and corey large are
equally guilty they neglected to flesh
out the supporting characters and lifted
a little too liberally from the likes of
battlestar galactica it even fails as a
straight-up action film with choppy
editing and uninspired battle sequences
the relative success of 2019's detective
pikachu and 2020 sonic the hedgehog
proved that there's an appetite for
light-hearted live-action and cgi
crossovers right now however 2021's tom
and jerry failed to strike the same
chord while it was just about passable
as a mindless kids movie unlike the
aforementioned films it gave teams and
childless adults no real reason to stick
around until the credits history's most
famous cat and mouse duo get up to all
the usual trouble as they collide in new
york city and the animation looks
fantastic even so the plot is paper thin
and the film's talented actors struggle
to get anything from it the story
unfolds in an upscale manhattan hotel
where jerry has taken up residence when
his presence puts a planned wedding
reception at risk new employee kayla
forrester played by chloe grace moretz
suggests hiring tom to help capture him
which the boss of course thinks is a
great idea they fight ruin the wedding
and then make up to save it in a
predictable fashion all to the backdrop
of a jarring hip-hop soundtrack sadly
even all features and supporting roles
cannot help the lacking plot or save
this misfire
released in april 2021 action thriller
vanquish has plenty of style though no
amount of neon huge shootouts can cover
for the complete lack of substance here
ruby rose stars a single mother victoria
a former drug mule who managed to turn
her life around she got a job as a
caretaker for damon hickey played by
morgan freeman he's a retired hero cop
who lives a secret life as a crime lord
victoria discovers this too late as
hickey kidnaps her daughter and demands
that she collect some debts for him
vanquish is essentially a handful of
forgettable gunfights each followed by
an equally dull chase sequence victoria
has to pick up cash at five different
locations and the same thing happens
every time she meets resistance resorts
to force and then takes off on her
motorcycle to deal with the next corny
gangster on her list ruby rose does her
best to make us care about what she's
doing but the sheer lack of character
development makes that a big ask of
audiences who hated the film almost as
much as the critics did this was the
third time that writer director george
gallo had worked with freeman in his
many years yet he still hasn't figured
out how to write for him richard roper
at the chicago sun times boldly said
that gallo burdens morgan freeman with
stupid lines meanwhile peter travers via
abc called freeman's participation in
the project a quote form of actor abuse
the paramount plus film infinite lives
up to its name in that it feels like
it's never going to end mark wahlberg
stars as evan mccauley a man suffering
with what he mistakenly believes to be
hallucinations he was diagnosed with
schizophrenia as a teen and has been
attempting to come to terms with his
visions ever since but everything he
thinks he knows about himself is thrown
into doubt when a secret group of
so-called infinites seek him out and
reveal that he's actually one of them
the infinites explained that his
hallucinations aren't really
hallucinations at all instead their
memories from countless past lives
explaining away a debilitating mental
illness as some kind of sci-fi deja vu
isn't a good look for any film and
that's far from the only issue here
training day director antoine fuqua does
his best to make the film flow but he's
working with a muddled matrix light
script that's more interested in world
building than character development the
presence of the miscast mark wahlberg
certainly doesn't help matters in fact
he makes them decidedly worse infinite
was hammered by critics when it dropped
on paramount's streaming service in june
2021 and the leading man was in the
firing line polygon argued that marky
mark and sci-fi simply don't mix asking
did we learn nothing from tim burton's
planet of the apes or m night
shyamalan's the happening
the original space jam didn't exactly
blow the critics away when it hit
cineplexes in 1996 but thanks largely to
a memorable supporting turn from bill
murray it went on to become a cult
favorite among millennials there's no
bill murray in the 2021 sequel space jam
a new legacy and in place of michael
jordan lebron james leads the line like
his predecessor james portrays himself
in the film in which he has to rescue a
fictionalized version of his son from a
villainous artificial intelligence
played by don cheadle you might be
wondering how such a premise ever got
past warner brothers execs until you see
the film and realize that it's 115
minutes of the studio aimlessly mashing
its ips together after his boy is
somehow sucked into the warner brothers
servers king james must act he follows
him into a virtual reality world created
by cheadle's character who promptly
sends james to toon world and orders him
to create a basketball team made up of
its inhabitants when he arrives however
they're all missing all except for bugs
bunny james and warner brothers iconic
carrot chomping rabbit set out to locate
the other tombs both james and cheadle
do their utmost to elevate this
glorified commercial for warner brothers
properties but it's beyond them both
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]